[Music]
since we're all relying on products to
complement our connected lives
we caught up with the tech lifestyle
expert to see some of the newest trends
carly knobloch she showed us some great
gadgets take the arlo essential indoor
security camera
super affordable it's under 100 bucks
use it in your home to check on babies
nannies or older people
she says it's got an automatic privacy
shield it's even great for a small
business owner who wants to monitor
his or her stock room or the main floor
and how many of us have broken our
glasses after dropping or stepping on
them
oh well don't worry so much about that
anymore with the flex on eyewear
it's got titanium frames
if you're active and you want your
glasses to keep up with you you want to
check out flexon eyewear they have these
technologically advanced
memory metal titanium frames and that
means you can
twist these you can flex these you can
bend them
they're going to return to the same
shape every time plus they come in a
wide range of styles and finishes
and with their flexible bridge and
temples they're more durable
lightweight and resistant than
traditional metal glasses now you can go
on any adventure and know your glasses
are going to keep up with you
there's also the my cloud home from wd
as families are amassing tons of photos
and videos
my cloud home a personal cloud storage
device it keeps all your files in one
spot with no monthly subscription fee